there's a lot of theories as to why we
kiss but some of it may have to do with
our earliest experiences on planet Earth
when we're infants through being kissed
by parents and also through nursing
through a lot of lip stimulation that
becomes Associated through neural
Pathways in our brain with these very
very positive emotions later in life
when we want to express ourselves that
way we probably do so using our mouths
there are some anthropologists that
think that the lips are What's called
the genital Echo so they mimic the
female genitals and shape composition
color and texture and they serve as a
reliable indicator of when a woman might
be ready to mate connection is
ultimately important for keeping us
together for keeping our bonds strong
for raising all of the different
hormones and neurotransmitters in our
bodies that make us maintain our
important relationships and kissing is a
big part of that
[Music]